CBS News confirms the Democratic Party
and Hillary Clinton's presidential
campaign helped pay for controversial
research into president Trump's ties to
Russia
The Washington Post first revealed the
Democrats connection to the research
dossier that leaked back in January
it contained ups and Stan she ated
claims connecting the President to
Russian interest
president Trump questioned the origin of
what he calls the fake dossier last week
he tweeted who paid for it Russia the
FBI or the DIMMs
or all jeopardizes in Washington with
these new revelations Jeff good morning
good morning since January the
allegations in the dossier have gained
credibility in the eyes of FBI agents
working the Russia investigation CBS
News confirmed earlier this year that
parts of it were being used as a road
map as agents unraveled alleged trunk
connections to Russia but with new ties
to the Clinton campaign coming to light
the president's supporters are once
again calling the Russia investigation
partisan originally commissioned by
anti-trump Republicans in the primary
the document was compiled by research
firm fusion GPS with information from
former British spy Christopher Steele
the folks behind me get us right over
the top but after Donald Trump's primary
victory the research didn't stop mark
Elias a lawyer working for the Clinton
campaign and the DNC hired Fusion GPS is
law firm Perkins cuy
confirmed that relationship in a letter
Tuesday which says in part fusion gps
approached perkins cuy in early March of
2016 to continue research that fusion
gps had conducted for one or more other
clients during the Republican primary
contest I have nothing to do with Russia
haven't made a phone call to Russia in
years the president has consistently
denied any connections to the Kremlin or
Russian operatives still there are three
congressional investigations looking
into the matter and Special Counsel
Robert Muller has been appointed to
investigate whether the Trump campaign
conspired with Russian operatives last
night a former spokesman for the Clinton
campaign tweeted if even a shred of that
dossier ends up helping Muller it will
prove money well spent to date the DNC
and Clinton sources have denied any
knowledge of any connection to
fusion GPS earlier this year it was
revealed that the FBI had agreed to pay
Christopher Steele but the bureau ended
the arrangement after Steele was
publicly identified Norah alright Jeff
thank you so much